[Applause]
our next guest is an academy
award-nominated grammy and tony winning
actress for her work in the film harriet
and the color purple on broadway please
welcome to the show cynthia revo
[Applause]
you freaking stand it hey welcome to the
amber ruffin show thank you cynthia
arrivo you are here because you are a
perfect human being
you are a broadway star a movie star a
tv star and the singer you're an
inspiration to any creative you are a
super model fashion baby i'm starting
there's no bounds you figured out how to
be your authentic self and it's
inspiring i love you
thank you
now
now we met on sunday at the tony awards
yes where you looked amazing so did you
everyone needs to take a look at you
look at my little friend which camera
this guy
just kidding this
one and that's her
yay
this is the prettiest thing how did you
become a perfect fashion baby
uh i don't even know if i'm a perfect
fashion baby i just love fashion i love
style and i love being able to express
myself in through that form um i have
wonderful people who help to create
things to make things to
mess around with the silly ideas i have
in my head and they let me play and
that's kind of what happens
yeah
um how many of you guys are shocked at
her accent
yeah
yeah
you know you know you don't see it
coming i don't
see it coming it's it's sneak up it
sneaks up on me and i like it good um
yes you were nominated for an oscar for
playing harriet tubman and harriet you
played aretha franklin on tv you want a
grammy and a tony for the color purple
yeah
it's amazing
keeping all that in mind what i want to
know is
what was it like to tour sister act in
the uk
crazy thank you for asking that question
nobody ever asks that question oh and it
was nuts
absolutely nuts we did it for
i want to say we did it for a year and a
half maybe 14 14 months and it was
mad
ma we went to every uh
city in the uk
some cities are wonderful other cities
are not so wonderful
so you go to like manchester and it's
incredible because it's like it feels
like like london really and truly you go
to liverpool there's like a feeling
about every everybody talks like that so
the accents are different see listening
to everyone and you're like what what's
that what's that sound you're making
it's different and and then you go to
sunderland and you're like where the am
i
i don't know where i am
this is
not where i live oh at all but it was
really really wonderful and i loved the
musical i loved singing i used to mess
around every night so there's this
there's a song at the end of the show
and once you start to spread it baby if
you let it love comes like right on back
to you
that is that's how it's supposed to
sound
okay i used to go i used to i would be i
would it would take such liberties so
i'd be love comes right on back to you
and it's like
finish the note
just finish it cynthia we've got to get
to the end of the
show but i loved it it was so much fun i
the costumes were fun it was spot fun
and sparkly and ridiculous and and i had
a great time doing it yeah but it was
long
i can't imagine being on tour for 14
months it's epic is that the longest
you've ever been on tour 14 months yes
and i will never do it again god bless
it that sounds terrible yeah but also
when someone
wants you to finish a note they are
wrong and you are right thank you very
much thank you
so
cynthia yeah you advocate for making
sure that you're paid the right amount
and having a team that knows how to do
your hair makeup and light you properly
when did you realize it was time to to
start asking these questions
when i came at my mother's womb
she came out talking about where where
can we turn down the overhead lights
thank you um it was it i i you know i i
have a great team who's brave enough to
like ride with me really and truly so
um
i would i think when i first started
doing shows and especially when i got
here when i when i did the color purple
and we started like branching out and
doing film and tv my team just like they
work with me and i ask them what i want
i ask them for what i need and they go
out and do it and and it's also like
once you've had experience
when it's not right
you
i'm a capricorn
um
what's your birthday january the eighth
ninth are you joking yes i'm telling the
truth
january the 8th january 9th both
capricorns that's right
terence january 13th 80 watts 80s what
79 bud what yeah are you joking no
that's wild why do you look younger than
me oh thank you
you look like a baby i had
[Applause]
um cheers did i get you a drink yes oh
good here you go um cheers to asking for
what you need always always and forever
that's good is it good yay that's good
yeah okay i mean gosh i remember
having to be like
i need you to have the supplies i need
so that i need it's just
i mean the fight oh my goodness
i remember i did this i did this um like
this gala thing and they had said you
don't need to bring your makeup but
we're gonna get you ready there and
we'll have makeup artists on site and
everything will be fine and always
here's the thing as a black girl you
know that does not mean [ __ ] so bring
your own makeup
so i brought my own makeup and i was
like i'll leave it there just in case i
remember i got to the table
where this makeup bless her heart
was supposed to be working on me and she
looked at me she goes
oh
and i was like is everything okay she's
like
i i don't think i have your color
i was like what what do you mean you
don't have my color what i i didn't i
thought i was just doing the models i
was like well i am one of them today
so have you not got the shades that i no
i don't have them i said all right hold
on a minute when i got my bag these are
the shades you need you should always
carry those colors with you
[Applause]
i just
but i guess the point is that you should
just never have to do that you know like
you're a makeup artist and so you should
expect anyone to be in your seat who
could be any color whatsoever and your
job is to do mine do makeup it isn't to
do just this makeup is to do makeup full
stop so so i just never wanted to
experience that anymore so i made sure i
have who i need on set with me and so i
don't ever have to ask those questions
and i know that they will always have
the colors that they need
yes
when i grow up i'm gonna be just like
you okay now it is time for the speed
round hit me these questions are very
important going they they determine who
wins the speed round okay okay it's you
versus you all right okay
good now okay uh-huh
i asked this of everyone
you're in dream girls what part do you
play laurel effie or deena
[Music]
i'm going to play laurel just because i
love
because i love that that moment at the
end
she loves jimmy
morelos me
when the rail and jimmy are through
[Applause]
easy
you know
that is the question for your buck it's
she got it there you go you're always
going to get random flaws after that you
have played a lot of icons but who do
you want to play you in your biopic oh i
don't know if we found her yet
i don't know that's not her yet
might she might somewhere and i know
that she might not even be bored she
might be in school right now who knows
but i'm looking forward to whoever does
it she might be sitting next i hope i'm
alive when it happens
that's it she might be sitting next to
me
i hope i meet her
i i think you're going to that would be
nice because i'll write it now you have
to choose one job for the rest of your
life yes broadway performer yes screen
actor yes or just straight up singer
oh with just one just one you only get
one
the lightning round is tough and it is
not fast
[Laughter]
oh i can't why must you do this to me
you have to choose one oh and the world
is waiting
i'm oh
i'm gonna say you know yeah you know
what yes i'm gonna say screen actually
because you know what you know what i'm
doing on screen playing a a witch that
sings so i'm still gonna be able to do
both
that's
right i could do it all on screen that's
right
wicked it's coming and it's going to be
good
god i can't wait to go see that okay
this is the last and most important
question okay years ago my friend and i
came to see you in the color purple on
broadway yes we cheered very loudly did
you see us yes yes
all right cynthia everyone
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you